ich bin h heute auf der Anuga der
weltgrößten lebensmittelfachmesse und
ich habe hier einige interessante
Neuheiten für euch getestet in meiner
Hand hier halte ich ein veganes Steak
das 100% pflanzlich ist und im
ungebratenen Zustand sogar wirklich
verdammt ähnlich einem echten Steak
aussieht und es sieht richtig gut aus
gucken wir mal wie es schmeckt nicht
unbedingt so wie ein echtes Steak aber
echt lecker und gerade für Veganer
glaube ich eine coole Alternative wenn
man noch mal ein Steak essen möchte ist
die legendäre
montreppe in dieser Dose hier befindet
sich kein normaler Thunfisch sondern
Veganer Thunfisch der sieht so aus wie
Thunfisch und gerade in so einem
Sandwich hier schmeckt das wirklich eins
zu ein krass also wenn man eine
Thunfisch Alternative sucht ist das
wirklich eine 10 von ze ich find es sehr
sehr krass und es ist keine Werbung ganz
wichtig es gibt hier auch eine Sache die
ist einfach unglaublich weil du kriegst
die nirgendwo in Deutschland glaubt mir
ich habe schon danach gesucht Martins
potato rolls die burgerbrote die Goldies
Berlin der beste Burger in Deutschland
Burger she Road der beste Burger der
Welt alle Burger Lden benutzen diese
burgerbns und wir haben Sie hier einfach
ein Traum